le mail percée saule pleureur vieux est
atteint par un champignon ces arbres
sont abattus
une décision prise suite à une
consultation d'experts en botanique donc
là c'était bas l'emplacement d'un arbre
qui n'est plus là qu'il ya déjà un tiers
des arbres de cette année qui ont dû
être abattus ou qui sont tombés à cause
de la maladie leur affaiblissement qui
sont aujourd'hui plus assez d'eau pour
se nourrir de l'âge aussi parce que
c'est des arbres qui ont plus de 40 ans
la rénovation du mail des sols un
engagement de la majorité municipale
coût de l'investissement plus de 2
millions d'euros une opération en
plusieurs phases des travaux sur le
quartier des sols et le quartier du parc
avant de restructurer la place centrale
la différence avec le projet actuel
c'est que la circulation piétonne
donc il reste bien sûr un my piétons et
aux circulations douces vélo se fera sur
un axe central
il y aura dans le nouveau projet pour
que ces mille mètres carrés de surface
végétale en plus par rapport à
l'existant et bien moi je suis contente
que les travaux se met en route parce
qu'à chaque tempête en avait toujours
peur cranach tombe sur quelqu'un
depuis déjà plusieurs années donc c'est
une bonne chose c'est très bien sauf que
ça m'a fait un peu bizarre quand ils ont
coupé tous les arbres
parce que la végétation c'était quand
même sympa après c'est vrai que ça cache
et la luminosité mais
j'espère qu'il y aura quand même
les habitants des deux quartiers ont été
consultés par la municipalité
mais certaines réserves persistent sur
le projet notamment olivier paréja
conseiller municipal qui souhaitent le
marquage de pistes cyclables sur la zone
partagée